[Aplausos]
[Música]
casi casi empatada con francia alemán es
el país de toda la unión europea que más
presupuesto militar tiene según los
datos recogidos por el banco mundial
casi una cuarta parte de todo el gasto
militar de los países que integran el
club comunitario corresponde a las
fuerzas armadas alemanas hablamos de la
bundeswehr que literalmente podría
traducirse como defensa federal queridos
amigos amigas alemania es uno de los
países con más tradición militar de todo
el planeta lo que como todos sabéis no
ha sido algo que haya traído consigo
grandes alegrías para la historia de la
humanidad pero evidentemente la
situación hoy en día es completamente
distinta
la bundeswehr fue fundada en 1955 diez
años después de la caída del régimen
nazi y del fin de la segunda guerra
mundial durante ese lapso de tiempo el
consejo de control aliado que controlaba
el país tras la gran guerra prohibió que
el país tuviera fuerzas armadas propias
y desmanteló y declaró ilegal cualquier
actividad militar relacionada con la
antigua berman las fuerzas armadas de la
alemania nazi eso fue así hasta que en
1955 esa prohibición fue levantada y la
alemania federal fundó las fuerzas
armadas que conocemos actualmente
claro que desde entonces ha llovido
mucho durante estos casi 70 años el
ejército alemán ha pasado por al menos
siete grandes reformas tanto de corte
estructural como estratégico de la
primera orientación basada en las
propias fuerzas armadas norteamericanas
a las dos últimas que se han traducido
en una enorme reducción de tamaño fijaos
[Aplausos]
tan solo entre finales de los 80 y
mediados de los 90 coincidiendo
lógicamente con el colapso de la unión
soviética y el fin de la guerra fría la
bundeswehr ha perdido unos 150.000
soldados y en total hasta el día de hoy
las fuerzas armadas de la alemania
occidental hoy alemania se han visto
reducirse su tamaño en un 60% claro que
esto no tiene por qué ser algo malo si
algo caracteriza a los ejércitos
modernos es que gracias a las nuevas
capacidades tecnológicas necesitan
muchos menos efectivos el problema es
que estas capacidades tecnológicas pues
exigen un montón de recursos y la
pregunta es se ha hecho este esfuerzo en
alemania cuenta la mayor potencia de la
unión europea con unas fuerzas armadas
bien equipadas y capaces de llevar a
cabo despliegues y misiones complejas
están las fuerzas armadas de alemania
preparadas para entrar en la guerra pues
bien veámoslo
[Aplausos]
[Música]
de perfil a los asuntos militares
alemania es con diferencia la primera
potencia económica de toda europa y en
términos de pib la cuarta de todo el
mundo tan solo por detrás de estados
unidos china y japón- sin embargo un
momento porque a pesar de su enorme
fuerza económica y de tener unas cuentas
públicas que están entre las más
saneadas del 'viejo continente' el
esfuerzo en defensa de alemania apenas
supone poco más del 1 por ciento de su
producto interior bruto y aunque el
gasto comenzó a incrementarse transar
anexión rusa de crimea bajo el liderazgo
por cierto de la entonces ministra de
defensa a ursula von der leyen todavía
sigue muy pero que muy por debajo del 2%
que como sabéis se exige la otan a sus
países miembros algo que bueno la verdad
tampoco debería llamarnos mucho la
atención prácticamente ningún integrante
de la otan cumple con ese requisito y al
fin y al cabo se supone que la defensa
de europa se llevaría a cabo de forma
colectiva
[Música]
sin embargo amigos el problema que tiene
alemania y que también tienen otros
muchos países es que a pesar de gastarse
más de 50 mil millones de euros cada año
esta cifra se destina casi por completo
a salarios y estructuras desastrosamente
planificadas y muchos gastos corrientes
y burocráticos y para colmo está enorme
burocracia y los interminables procesos
de contratación han hecho que la llegada
del nuevo equipamiento se demonio mucho
en el tiempo o simplemente se quede en
standby es decir el problema de la manía
no sólo es que apenas destinan a defensa
a poco más del 1 por ciento de su pib
sino sobre todo que la mayor parte de
ese dinero que se destina a engordar
estructuras ineficientes que nada
absolutamente nada tienen que ver con
las capacidades operativas por ser
gráficos y sin pretender ofender a nadie
una parte sustancial del dinero se
destina a pagar los salarios a señores
de 50 y muchos años en muchos casos
seguramente con abultadas barrigas
cerveceras cuyo trabajo consiste en
pasarse el día a día en una mesa de
oficina y eso digamos que eso no es el
prototipo de lo que todos entendemos
como un ejército operativo
así que claro en el caso alemán no se
debería hablar tanto de la falta de
esfuerzo en defensa como sobre todo de
la mala inversión y planificación de las
fuerzas armadas al fin y al cabo 50 mil
millones de euros no son precisamente
poco dinero es mucho más dinero por
ejemplo de lo que cada año se gastan
defensa con el sur casi duplica lo que
será hasta australia y es más del doble
del presupuesto de israel y si lo sea
alemania es mucho muchísimo más grande
que israel o corea del sur pero aquí
hablamos fundamentalmente de capacidades
operativas y como veréis alemania estaba
muy pero que muy por detrás de estos dos
países y el problema amigos tiene que
ver en gran medida con este gráfico
fijaos tan sólo el 18 por ciento del
gasto militar alemán se invierte en
equipos militares una cifra que también
está por debajo del mínimo del 20 por
ciento que marca la otan y el caso es
que precisamente por su pasado histórico
lo cierto es que los políticos alemanes
siempre se han mostrado muy pero que muy
reacios a comprar armas
[Música]
socialmente el gasto en defensa tampoco
es una baza electoral según un sondeo
realizado en 2017 apenas el 9% de los
alemanes consideraban importante
aumentar el gasto en defensa frente al
91% que lo consideraba irrelevante
inadecuado o no tenía opinión la postura
alemana desde la posguerra ha tenido en
la diplomacia blanda su gran apuesta en
política exterior una postura que como
se ha demostrado con ucrania puede tener
agujeros
[Música]
pero bien la cuestión es que esta falta
de gasto en equipamiento militar pues ha
hecho de alemania un país altamente
dependiente de la otan o mejor dicho de
los eeuu para todo aquello que tenga que
ver con los asuntos militares al fin y
al cabo tenemos que tener en cuenta que
alemania es 3 japón es el segundo país
del mundo con más instalaciones
militares estadounidenses y por curioso
que os pueda resultar el gigante
norteamericano tiene estacionados aquí
en este territorio a muchos más soldados
americanos que los que por ejemplo
tienen corea del sur o un país que
recordemos por eso está técnicamente en
guerra hablamos en total de más de 35
mil efectivos resumiendo la falta de
planificación la falta de gasto en
equipamiento y la dependencia de los
eeuu se traduce extrema de jade en unas
bundes vea en un estado lamentable y no
no estamos exagerando lo más mínimo no
importa a donde mires hay disfunción
oficial alemán de alto rango en el
cuartel general de la bundeswehr con
semejante percal tras la invasión rusa
de ucrania los políticos alemanes de
repente parecen haberse dado cuenta de
bien que la guerra en europa no es un
escenario completamente descartable o
cuanto menos que la disuasión europea
hoy por hoy no vale de mucho
esta es una situación que simple y
llanamente ha pillado por sorpresa a los
mandamases de berlín y lo cierto es que
a día de hoy de tener que entrar en
combate es posible que la bundes vea
apenas pudiera soportar unos pocos días
de guerra y ojo porque esto no es algo
que digamos sólo nosotros fijaos el
alemán despreocupado rodeado de amigos
con un nivel de vida en aumento sin
preocupaciones por la seguridad que
piensa que si hay un problema los
estadounidenses se encargarán de ello es
cosa del pasado en heart brose
presidente de la academia federal de
estudios de seguridad
los alemanes adormecieron en una falsa
sensación de seguridad con la creencia
de que nunca habría otra guerra europa
el resultado es que durante dos
generaciones hemos olvidado cómo
defendernos armin para berger director
ejecutivo del fabricante de armas
rheinmetall pues bien para solucionar
esta larga decadencia militar de la cual
os hablaremos con todo detalle en un
momento el nuevo gobierno de souza
anunció un presupuesto extraordinario
histórico para modernizar las fuerzas
armadas según lo seguro que la mayoría
de vosotros recordáis esta noticia
alemania impulsará el gasto militar en
el último cambio histórico alemania
canalizar a 100.000 millones de euros
este año hacia un fondo para modernizar
el ejército además el gobierno de soult
también se ha comprometido a alcanzar el
2 por ciento del pib en gasto militar
anual para el año 2024 y la cuestión es
como de difícil es realmente la tarea
que tiene alemania por delante para
poner al día sus fuerzas armadas cuáles
han sido los efectos de tanta dejadez en
defensa cuáles deben ser las prioridades
de alemania a la hora de invertir todo
ese dinero en los próximos años pues
bien veámoslo
[Música]
un ejército en ruinas
el antaño temido ejército alemán ahora
es poco más que un montón de tanques
aviones helicópteros y submarinos que en
muchos casos no pueden disparar ni volar
ni tampoco navegar y ojo que estas
fueron básicamente las conclusiones del
socialdemócrata hans-peter bartels ex
comisario para las fuerzas armadas del
bundestag el parlamento alemán tras
realizar un extenso informe en 2019
sobre las capacidades militares del país
un informe repleto de conclusiones
demoledoras
[Música]
el informe sirvió para plasmar una
realidad incómoda para el gobierno el
ejército alemán carece incluso de
equipos críticos suficientes como
chalecos antibalas equipos de visión
nocturna helicópteros de transporte o
radios para comunicaciones seguras y la
escasez no es algo puntual sino
estructural tanto es así que por poneros
un ejemplo en una visita de funcionarios
estadounidenses a lituania éstos se
quedaron consternados al ver que el
personal de la bundeswehr se comunicaba
con teléfonos móviles inseguros por lo
contar con suficientes radios militares
encriptadas
no había ni un soldado alemán
familiarizado con el sistema de radio
utilizado allí o que hubiera sido
instruido para saber usarlo cuando se
trata de equipamiento disponible en
ejércitos internacionales la bundeswehr
suele ser el eslabón más débil de la
cadena informe del parlamento alemán y
esto no es todo de todo el equipamiento
militar que tiene alemania en sus
inventarios tan sólo una pequeña
fracción está listo para el despliegue y
luego una buena parte del material que
tienen en funcionamiento no ha cumplido
las expectativas a la hora de realizar
operaciones
la lista de excepciones en el inventario
alemán es larga muy pero que muy larga
por ejemplo ahí tenemos el caso de la
fragata de la clase f 125 badén
württemberg una nueva clase de fragatas
de la que el gobierno alemán compró
cuatro unidades en 2007 y que después de
años de retrasos y enormes sobrecostes
fueron entregadas a la armada con
sobrepeso y muchas limitaciones
operativas respecto al proyecto original
algo que ha imposibilitado que las
fragatas a día de hoy cumplan con la
función para las que fueron diseñadas
incluso tuvieron que ser devueltas al
fabricante una vez entregadas para hacer
más modificaciones algo que nunca antes
había pasado en la historia de alemania
la armada alemana decidió devolver su
nueva fragata sobredimensionada al
fabricante naval esta navidad pero
esperad porque hay mucho más
[Música]
por ejemplo un batallón de panzer gran
adhieres que participaba en un ejercicio
de la otan e noruega se vio falto de
gafas de visión nocturna y
ametralladoras meg-3 y bueno qué queréis
que os diga el resultado fue tan
chistoso como bochornoso alemania no
puede explicar el uso de palos de escoba
en lugar de ametralladoras en un
ejército de la otan en un ejercicio de
la otan
y ojo porque lo más lamentable de toda
su historia es que para poder participar
en el ejercicio tuvieron que recabar
prestados más de 14.300 equipos de 56
unidades distintas de la bundeswehr y
aun con esas se quedaron cortos y por
supuesto esto no es una excepción es la
tónica en cualquier rama del ejército
sea de tierra mar o aire pero queréis
otro ejemplo puedes fijaos
[Música]
solo nueve de sus cincuenta y nelly
copero trata que tiger y menos del 30
por ciento de sus cazas eurofighter y
tornado podrían volar a finales del 2018
el motivo la falta de mantenimiento y de
piezas de recambio disponibles en los
stocks de las fuerzas armadas alemanas
hacen que los ya de por sí escasos
equipos hayan terminado almacenados como
si fueran una especie de reserva
inoperativa tanto es así que la fuerza
aérea de la luftwaffe ha llegado a haber
renuncias de pilotos que se han ido
frustrados porque simple y llanamente no
podían volar los pilotos alemanes no
están recibiendo suficientes horas de
vuelo el problema es que la luz base no
tiene suficientes aviones capaces de
volar para que sus pilotos vuelen y ya
me diréis para qué demonios ha sido en
pilotos que no pueden volar
[Música]
y seguimos porque tres cuartas partes de
lo mismo pasa con los tanques leopard 2
la joya de la corona de la infantería
pesada alemana y de los cuales tan solo
la mitad están operativos y más sólo 150
de los 350 blindados puma están listos
para usarse de los 15 aviones de
transporte a400m sólo 3 estaban en
condiciones de volar en 2018 y una
temporada en la que ni uno solo de los
seis submarinos alemanes podía navegar
entendéis ahora porque alemania no ha
enviado casi nada de equipamiento a
ucrania para apoyar su resistencia
contra la invasión rusa si apenas tienen
equipamiento funcional para ellos como
para encima regalárselo a otro país
bueno más allá de que tampoco es que
parezca hacerle mucha gracia a la verdad
en el corto plazo no tenemos nada
disponible que podamos proporcionar
realmente de forma rápida y puntual
anna-lena verbo ministra de exteriores
de alemania el caso es que al margen de
esta cuestión todas estas carencias
conllevan también una clara falta de
entrenamiento y preparación de la tropa
algo que por supuesto pues también
afectaría mucho a su moral en caso de
combate la huida de pilotos de la lupa
fe es sólo un ejemplo pero si miramos
las cifras de reclutamiento lo vemos
todavía más claro el ejército alemán
lucha por atraer a los tan necesitados
reclutas el número de nuevos soldados
cayó el año pasado aún histórico de
20.000 haber pensado un momento con
semejante percal quién va a estar
motivado para meterse en estas fuerzas
armadas pues la cuestión que mucho
seguro que os estáis preguntando
llegados a este punto es pero pide
solución todo este desaguisado son 100
mil millones de presupuesto
extraordinario suficientes como para
reconstruir unas fuerzas armadas que
están hechas trizas en que debería
invertir alemania todo ese dinero pues
bien descubramos lo
[Música]
una lección aprendida
amigos amigas con todo lo que os
acabamos de contar seguro seguro que la
mayoría lo tenéis muy claro las fuerzas
armadas alemanas están obsoletas y no
sólo obsoletas sino en muchos casos en
estado casi decrépito y eso va a pesar
de gastarse más de 50 mil millones de
euros cada año de locos pues bien esto
es precisamente lo que explica el
aparente histórico cambio de paradigma
que alemania parece querer dar a su
política de defensa es hoy por supuesto
también los 100.000 millones de euros
que han aprobado para reconstruir sus
fuerzas armadas luego que por cierto en
el curso de los próximos cinco años si
les sumamos el gasto corriente les
permitirá cumplir con el compromiso del
2% del pib de gasto militar que exige la
otan la cuestión es en que deberían
gastarse toda esta pasta pues será la
lista de la compra de berlín con una
cantidad de dinero que equivale
prácticamente a todo lo que una economía
como ecuador produce durante un año pues
bien lo cierto es que por ahora la lista
de la compra para la defensa alemana es
prácticamente un secreto sin embargo un
momento porque hay varias pistas y
varias conjeturas que podemos hacer
sobre qué equipos sí o sí estarán o al
menos deberían estar entre las próximas
adquisiciones alemanas
hasta el momento lo que se ha hecho
público alemania es que comprar a 35
cazas de quinta generación efe 35 es
considerado el caza más avanzado del
mundo para reemplazar así sus viejos
tornados y con ellos poder tener la
superioridad aérea en caso de conflicto
también adquirirán 15 eurofighters con
capacidad de guerra electrónica y drones
armados equipamiento que en algunos
casos fue anunciado antes de lanzar el
fondo especial en total alemania espera
gastar unos 41.000 de esos 100.000
millones de euros en la fuerza aérea y
unos 19 mil millones en la armada con
los que se espera que adquieran
submarinos fragatas y corbetas así como
barcos de combate multipropósito
por su parte el ejército de tierra se
llevaría unos 17.000 millones de euros
en equipamiento lo que se utilizaría
prácticamente por completo para
actualizar y poner operativos los
blindados tanques y artillería que ya
tiene el ejército alemán y por supuesto
la última pata sobre la mesa que
alemania busca solucionar con esta
enorme cantidad de recursos es la falta
de suministros de equipamientos básicos
por ejemplo según el más él es experta
en seguridad del consejo alemán de
relaciones exteriores casi 21.000
millones se destinarán a nuevas
tecnologías de comunicaciones como por
ejemplo radios seguras y de buena
seguridad y también al propio
equipamiento personal de los soldados la
cuestión es ser a todo esto suficiente
pues seguramente no como ya habéis visto
el estado de la bundeswehr es complicado
muy complicado
[Música]
pero sin duda marcará un antes y un
después para el ejército alemán un antes
y un después que debería ir acompañado
sí o sí de una reestructuración del
gasto para eliminar todas las
estructuras militares zombies que
consumen muchos recursos pero que no son
operativas estructuras que son las
culpables de que el dinero no ayuda para
la tecnología militar y mantenimiento
sino a otros menesteres y amigos amigas
esta tarea es mucho pero que mucho más
importante que simplemente gastar más y
más y llegar al 2% del pib que es por
ejemplo lo que hace grecia la cuestión
es que están los políticos alemanes
dispuestos a hacerlo al final las
fuerzas armadas suelen ser uno de los
mayores empleadores en casi cualquier
país y claro meter la mano en este
sentido pues suele toparse con grandes
resistencias y todo eso por no olvidar
lo difícil que es superar viejos vicios
fija 11 de julio de 2022 alemania
acusada de hacer recortes furtivos en
defensa el presupuesto de defensa alemán
disminuye una vez que se elimina el
impacto del fondo especial de 100 mil
millones de euros según los documentos
oficiales citados por el periódico bild
los críticos dicen que el fondo único
estaba ocultando los recortes en el
gasto recurrente pero llegado hasta aquí
turno para ti sabías que las fuerzas
armadas alemanas estaban en estado
creéis que la solución para solucionarlo
pasa por meter más dinero o por el
contrario crees que con 50 mil millones
de euros al año es más que suficiente y
el problema es cómo se ha estado
gastando ese dinero pues déjanos tus
opiniones por aquí abajo en los
comentarios y si este vídeo ha resultado
interesante no olvidéis dar a like y
suscribiros a visual político para estar
al tanto de todas nuestras novedades una
vez más muchas gracias por estar ahí un
saludo y hasta la próxima
[Música]